animal crossing basically one lockdown
you know everybody was playing that
i wanted to find out
um how your work all of you fits into
that larger scene of non-violent video
game output the work for hire that we do
a lot of the projects that we pick out
are what we kind of see as games for
good right it's kind of what we look at
it and there's a few key ones and one in
particular was just launched called
venture valley which is a great example
right so it was built um in conjunction
with an american charity called the
singleton foundation and one of their
really big focuses about promoting
financial literacy right so helping you
know children and people as they move
into college to kind of understand
finances managing their finances and if
they were to then go into business you
know how would they uh kind of go about
doing that right and so they wanted to
develop this game called venture valley
that is a game that uses you know game
design principles it's a city builder a
strategy game at heart but really the
the intent is to then teach people about
financial literacy and help them kind of
understand uh that those sorts of ideas
and it's tied into them the chart the
sort of donations that the charity makes
to various colleges and and sort of
sponsorship in regards to um
scholarships and things like that so
there's a huge component there that kind
of helps people move from the game and
then into um actual sort of higher
education and things like that so that's
kind of how our work for hire fits in
and then roip
um they're
part of what we sort of see is that the
broader wholesome games market right so
games that really want to put a focus on
kind of storytelling and
games that kind of have a greater sense
of purpose i think in what they want to
say right they're they're entertainment
games you know they're fun they're games
and that's always a really core
component but they have an element of
story to them that kind of touches on
you know maybe more sensitive areas of
you know sort of emotion or kind of life
experience and things like that so pine
hearts one of the games that we're
building at the moment is about a
character who's lost their father
recently right and it's about them kind
of coming to terms with that loss and
understanding their character growth and
how that develops over the course of the
game and it's still very much a
light-hearted puzzle game you know
that's very accessible but it does have
these themes underneath the players if
they want to engage in can kind of
scratch away and find those those kind
of deeper meanings that we hope you know
make that game a little more enriching
right than if it was sort of just a
puzzle game or something like that so um
that's kind of how our two sides of the
business kind of fit into that that sort
of sphere excellent and what about you
let's see what with what you do at media
uh
molecule sorry how does that fit into
the larger scene of non-violent video
game output
well um
all of media molecules output in some
way has been related to creativity which
and what's more non-violent than
creativity really um
the act of creation is something that
you know we've always been really really
interested in media molecule and of
empowering people
our players to create themselves the
creation stuff in dreams i mean the the
community recently has just
you know gone into the stratosphere with
the sort of stuff that they're producing
um the mps which is coming up on sunday
blood plug um is uh just an entirely
joyful explosion of creativity and
people you know presenting their their
insights to the world if you know what i
mean what's going on in their head
do you think
jude that non-violent video games
get enough credit
in the industry today
i think
yeah i think they do i think there's you
know there's very few video games that
are violent it's just i guess you know
some of the more violent ones have got
big budgets and that's what people see
it kind of goes back to this movement of
consumer buying behavior um people are
choosing to
to buy products and services that are
more impact driven or and maybe they are
choosing less violent as well i mean i
saw there was a really good statistic
last year um during when we were in you
know proper lockdown um
that talked about um you know the the
sales of violent video games had gone
down because people had felt that life
was just so stressful enough that they
didn't want to be more stressed out
while playing um so they were choosing
more social games more
um well less violent games so i think
that that could have a big impact on on
the types of games that we play um i
think there will always be kind of an
element of violent video games there you
know it's down to personal choice what
you enjoy playing but um i think we'll
start to see much more
either games developed with uh um
with a more kind of ethical lens um
or content within existing games
that
kind of promotes other kind of uh impact
will be weaved into it as well um lissy
i wanted to ask you you were talking
about the community and creativity and
and this like
this burst of awesomeness that you're
seeing um so there's clearly a demand
for non-violent video games do you see
that
increasing overtime or do you think it's
just a fad because perhaps it's just a
generational thing at the moment what do
you think what's your take on it
no i definitely see it increasing i mean
um
the lockdown effect is definitely i
think has had an effect on people and
animal crossing basically one lockdown
you know
18 year old daughter and i noticed that
like she'll play shooty games and
violent games as much as anybody but
the thing that she loves is creating
stuff you know um whether it's sims
which she's obsessed with
um or and trying to think well she still
plays minecraft at 18 years years old
you know because she just likes
making them worlds um and hanging out
there with her pals right
uh and i don't see it's not i don't i
don't see any that becoming less of a
thing really you know
and particularly as let's face it the
world is you know not the best place
right now
um i think people want escapes that
don't remind them of the rubbish that's
going on
outside their own front door you know um
i think people want to
they want to collaborate with people
they want to connect with people on the
other side of the world they want to
you know just get as much joy as they
can our life so i think it's only going
to build and build and build i think the
the uh appetite for
stuff that just makes you think or
create or relax is just only going to
build really
absolutely i agree um especially as a
big minecraft fan uh won't give away my
age i'm definitely older than 18. um i
wanted to ask uh rob
um do you think that i mean just
generally speaking like there's
definitely demand you know having spoken
to everyone here for uh non-violent
video games and i definitely play a lot
of non-violent video games myself
um i mean do you think they get enough
credit do you think the indies do you
think the non-violent video games do you
think that all of that needs to get more
credit more press that we should be sure
to get more about it rob what do you
think yeah i think it's certainly not
going to hurt for sure yeah you know
it's it's definitely i guess for a
situation like us here where a lot of
you're getting a game to market rook
sometimes has to revolve around well now
we need to pitch this to a publisher
right now this needs to we need to have
someone help us bring this to market
either through funding or through
distribution and you know marketing and
things like that you know the more
success stories you're able to point to
then the more persuasive your argument
can be right and that's only going to
then help more of those stories get out
and it just kind of snowballs from there
right so you know if we're able to to
kind of push that and have games you
know non-violent games take more of a
stage and in the in the industry then
it's only going to help more of those
those stories come forward right and and
publishers will be willing to take more
of a risk you know on a market that
might not be as big as the the shooter
or the racer market or whatever right
you know your your call of duty's and
you know your annual releases in those
sense right you're you're not needing to
compete with them there's a there's a
defined market that enjoys those games
and you can really point to them and say
look there's this many people that would
like to buy this game and so this is a
really viable proposition you know um so
now i think that that can only help but
i can only echo what what judy and lucia
said i think there's there's never been
more appetite for for these sorts of
products and i don't think that's going
anywhere it's only getting bigger and
bigger is you know as especially as as
games become more accessible as well you
know just the way that platforms and
technology has been so democratized you
know you can play a game on your phone
and then on your pc and then on your
your switch and it's the same game and
it's the consistent experience
throughout you know that's only going to
bring more people in and then i think as
that happens then you just get more and
more sort of a variety of experiences
right how has the industry
changed
would you say um from when you started
and you made your first steps leaving
abertay to now how would you say it's
changed for you
i mean it's it's grown
hugely um is first i think it's i think
the perception of gaming has changed as
well it's no longer kind of niche and
geeky it's for everyone um of all ages
um you know it's not a particular type
of person that plays a game now it's
everyone so i think that's been a
massive change and i think how games are
being used and applied outside of being
entertainment games as well has really
grown so
um when i started off kind of the first
the first spin out um at abertay i think
people just thought we were crazy just
thought we were mental they were like
why are you trying to teach people to
learn through games you know it wasn't
really uh
a body of research it was quite early
days the area that we focus on as well
which is the impact side you know even
10 years ago and kind of setting up
playmob
um
you know we were
you know people kind of look at us and
kind of go well are you a charity
because you're doing good or are you a
company it's like no we're a profit with
purpose business um and when we were
going out to talk to game developers it
was
csr and impact wasn't really on um it is
on a few people's radars but not many um
whereas now i mean that's just exploded
as well you know how can you engage your
players and making a difference because
players consumers want that too and so i
think there's been a huge change in um
consumer attitudes and spending um
behaviors that have also influenced what
we do in the games industry as well how
do you all begin planning your games do
you start with the goal do you work
backwards i've got no idea so
rob how do you begin planning your games
if it's not a client thing and it's your
game that you're starting yourself where
where do you start how do you start for
sure that's a great question um so i
mean we the way that we kind of approach
it is we always like to start with a
theme right there's i think the way that
we want to make games is that we need to
say something with the game there needs
to be a kind of purpose to it um there
needs to be some sort of moral argument
or something that we're trying to
communicate and so we always try and
establish that theme of like what's the
emotional take away from this experience
before we even understand what the game
mechanically is going to be it's like we
want to understand what we want to kind
of express
and i think that's really important
because you can use that to just
facilitate so much decision making in
the game um because i think it's really
easy to kind of fall into a trap where
you you think mechanically okay this is
the game we're building and then you
just look to other games and then you
just automatically start putting in
features from other games um and that
can be really helpful because you don't
want to reinvent the wheel in a lot of
cases but you know if you start with
theme then you can start to think about
well you know before we put this feature
in let's think is it actually suitable
or not you know does this facilitate our
theme or does this you know damage it in
some way and then that can actually let
you make some really creative decisions
where you maybe don't include something
that you might expect from that sort of
genre trope right or you you augment
that feature in some way that makes it
communicate your theme better um so
that's where we always start and then
from there you know it's just about
bringing the team in and making sure
that everyone feels like they understand
what it is that we're building and
getting their input you know we're a
very collaborative studio so it's all
about making sure that everyone really
gets to put their stamp on the game um
and really gets to feel like they have a
sense of ownership and understanding of
what their their part in it is so um and
then from there it just becomes you know
matter of planning and executing and
just figuring out what our budgets and
our teams are going to look like and we
kind of build from there but i think the
most exciting part for me is that
initial establishment of what are we
actually trying to see right why are we
building this game oh 100 because as a
gamer
you know you can feel that when you're
playing yeah you can't hundred percent
you've got i sometimes go to bed
thinking about the themes of the game
and thinking about gamer you get really
obsessed with that element not just you
know the mechanics of things all the
time so it's interesting